pour en parler nous sommes avec denis
jacquet entrepreneurs président de
l'association parrainé la croissance
bonsoir denis jacquet merci d'être avec
nous en direct
38e jour donc de confinement les
frontières sont fermées d'économies est
à l'arrêt les entrepreneurs souffre il
semble que ce soit votre cas vous vous
travaillez entre miami et paris mais
vous êtes bloqués à paris vous dites
vous la tension le déconfinement ne va
pas assez vite pour quelle raison je
pense qu'en fait aujourd'hui ce qu'on
paye principalement mais c'est la non
préparation nous économies occidentales
main si on regarde bien ce qui se passe
vous prenez la corée vous prenez le
vietnam vous prenez hong kong qui est
quand même la plus grosse densité au
monde huit mille personnes au kilomètre
carré
moins de quarante morts donc henry à
force de braquer les caméras tous les
soirs sur ce ce ce chapelet qui est
juste presque indécent du nombre de
morts quotidiens je ne rêve même pas
comprendre comment laisse passer ça à la
télé aujourd'hui on a l'impression que
la france meurt du coup tout le monde
est inquiet pense que retourner au
travail est dangereux parce qu'on
tombait malade la réalité c'est que pour
l'instant nous avons trente personnes
hospitalisées mais trente personnes
mortes surtout pour 100000 habitants et
qu'on vient à peine de dépasser les
chiffres de la grippe de 2018 et que
pour préserver je le comprends c'est un
choix politique difficile mais un moment
donné ce qu'on demande à un président de
la république c'est d'assurer le futur
de la plus grande partie de la
population dans quand vous avez 30
personnes pour cent mille qui meurt
quand vous avez deux perles dans la
majorité des départements français -
deux personnes dans des lits d'hôpitaux
aujourd'hui à moins de deux personnes
pour 100 me dans les lits d'hôpitaux
égaux tous concentre sur le grand test
et sur paris et que vous cantonniers
pour autant il vous consignes et 68
millions d'individus au risque mais
c'est plus un risque maintenant on le
sait c'est une récession qui est
officiellement déclarée qui va se
traduire par des morts par des
dépressions par des emplois qui nous
sont recréeront jamais et
démocratiquement part à une seule
certitude c'est qu'aucun candidat
démocrate ne pourra l'emporter dans les
dom et mocratie dans les années qui
viennent je crois que tout le monde a
oublié la leçon de l'histoire c'est qu'à
chaque fois qu'il ya eu des grandes
récessions dans les années qui ont suivi
ce sont toujours des populistes qui sont
arrivés au pouvoir donc
je pense qu'on prend l'un mort est
toujours un morges pas en train de dire
que ce n'est pas important
mais cette situation d'un virus qui ne
tue pas il tue uniquement parce que nous
ne sommes pas préparés parce que nous
n'avons pas de masque nous n'avons pas
de respirateur nos personnels
hospitaliers sont débordés mais quand la
crise a été bien préparé la lie le
prouve
vous n'avez quasiment pas de mort et
l'allemagne plus près de nous le prouve
avec très peu de morts mais 25 mille
lits d'hôpitaux des respirateurs un
personnel qui était prêt qui d'ailleurs
accueilli nos trucs donc quand on parle
avec tous les mais j'étais toujours en
débat avec un épidémiologiste qui disait
effectivement si vous me demandez à moi
médecins de prendre une décision bien
sûr que je vais confiné longtemps parce
que mon rôle c'est de sauver les gens
si j'ouvre mes zones mézières de
médecins et que je pense aux dégâts
qu'on est en train de poser dans la
société je crois que c'était la première
fois que j'entendais un médecin aussi
humble et est aussi ouvert là
effectivement peut-être qu'on doit se
poser la question de savoir si pour
sauver quelques milliers de personnes
supplémentaires on doit plonger dans
l'indigence des millions et c'est en ce
que ce compte est en train de faire donc
donc je n'arrive pas à comprendre cette
politique généralisée du confinement
je n'arrive pas à comprendre qu'on dès
qu'on finisse pas plus vite donnez moi
de me choquer mais c'est pourtant la
politique qui est pratiqué partout dans
le monde y compris en asie où il ya eu
quand même plusieurs milliers de morts
on ne connaît pas d'ailleurs peut-être
les chiffres exacts en chine que je n'ai
été sous-estimé en allemagne ait des
morts également plusieurs centaines j'ai
pas 5000 morts plusieurs milliers de
morts
tout le monde joue le confinement alors
qu'on n'ait pas été préparés c'est une
chose vous reprochez peut-être au
gouvernement d'en faire trop détriment
de l'économie d'en faire trop en faveur
peut-être de la santé de nos concitoyens
sans doute les plus fragiles
effectivement oui mais je pense que
pourquoi les économies principalement
aujourd'hui une seule qui est sûrement
menti sur ses chiffres et c'est la chine
néanmoins vous remarquerez que même si
ces 80 milles 1 sur 1 10 ans et demi de
personnes
franchement nous sommes comme le disait
malheureusement raul tu sais même pas
l'épaisseur du trait de plume ça ne
changera rien à la démographie chinoise
je rappelle que 40 mm 80000 c'est énorme
il faut savoir qu aux etats unis la
grippe en 2018 a fait 76 victimes
donc aujourd'hui on est très très loin
de ce conte donc et surtout les autres
pays
avi aujourd'hui cette épidémie n'a pas
tué elle s'est propagé rapidement mais
beaucoup moins rapidement avec moins de
morts pourquoi ne pas devoir parce que
c'est un virus qui est pas extrêmement
dangereux il est extrêmement dangereux
pour les gens qui ont des comorbidités
n'est qu'ils ont principalement des
hommes et qui sont plus de 75 ou 80 ans
mais aujourd'hui on empêche de
travailler non pas cela mais tous les
autres et en asie on a mis très vite les
plus âgés à l'écart pour qu'il soit
protégé que surtout il n'y ait pas
d'effets les effets minimum sur ces gens
là et les autres pouvaient travailler
parce que pourquoi aujourd'hui notamment
une femme qui a 35 ans et qui travaille
à une chance sur un milliard d'êtres de
se retrouver en réanimation dans un
hôpital donc du coup tous les états s'y
sentait qu est-ce qu on est aujourd'hui
il est clairement il est il est très
clair qu'aujourd'hui en tout cas le
chiffre que tout le monde a donné dans
tous les pays occidentaux c'est que plus
de 80% des gens qui meurent meurent
parce qu'on n'a pas le temps de les
traiter parce qu'ils ont des
comorbidités parce que ce sont des
hommes de plus de 75 ou 80 ans donc on
interdit aux gens de venir travailler
dit maintenant mais je veux pas je vais
être malade les malades de quoi 80 2 %
des gens ne se sont même pas aperçus
qu'ils avaient le virus donc ce que je
dis simplement c'est que on ne mesure
pas le seul dans le monde aujourd'hui et
c'est d'ailleurs étonnant parce qu'on
l'accuse toujours d'être à peu un idiot
qui est rom qu'il a dit mais on ne peut
pas confier la décision uniquement à des
médecins il faut aussi là confiait des
intellectuels à des entrepreneurs à des
économistes parce que eux au moins
savent mesurer que sion on doit faire un
choix un moment donné qui est très dur à
faire mais si on doit avoir quelques
centaines de malades en plus quelques
millièmes mort en plus mais qu on sauve
des centaines de millions de personnes
malheureusement il faut faire le choix
de la majorité de ceux qui lisent et
donc aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut
comprendre aussi c'est que ceux qui vont
mourir les toutes petites et moyennes
entreprises
nous vous nous ce sont des entreprises
et des jobs que nous ne retrouverons
jamais c'est ça qui est terrible dans
cette crise
merci beaucoup denis jacquet entre eux
doivent président de l'association
parrainé
la croissance merci d'avoir été en
direct sur rt france elle